okay remember if you ever shop on
amazon.com the shopping you do can send
us a little kickback so that every time
you buy something we get around seven
percent of that purchase back and
there's no better thing than taking a
little money away from a huge
corporation and redirecting it to
independent media what you do is before
you shop you go to david pakman.com
slash amazon and over the last week we
saw a number of Dungeons and Dragons
handbooks purchased by our audience I
was talking about Dungeons and Dragons
with a friend the other day I truly
don't understand I've asked many people
are there fixed rules or not in Dungeons
and Dragons because in the few times
I've seen the game played it sort of
seems like the players are making up the
story of what happens and how these
battles and different things go I still
have not gotten a straightforward answer
about whether yes there are fixed rules
here or there's an element of you just
sort of make it up as we go along but
clearly some experts on this issue in
our audience also somebody thank you by
the way for purchasing a $1,500 camera
through our link over the last week my
my suspicions are that this is the same
person who spent about ten thousand
dollars on camera equipment through our
link over the last year huge thank you
to you and remember going to david
pakman.com slash amazon before you shop
is the way to support our show with the
shopping you already plan to do